en el vídeo pasado empezamos a estudiar
qué sucede durante la meiosis y siendo
más precisos en la meiosis 1 y para
hacer todavía más precisos en la
aprobase 1 y dedicamos un buen tiempo en
la pro fase 1 por algunas cosas
interesantes que suceden ahí algunas de
las cosas que suceden son iguales a las
de la profa se de la mitosis donde la
envoltura nuclear desaparece justo como
por aquí o comienza a desaparecer
también los cromosomas pasan a su forma
condensada esto que tenemos aquí que
tiene esta forma clásica que puedes ver
en un microscopio pero lo que es único
lo que es interesante de la meiosis 1 y
en particular de la profa 1 es que
sucede el entrecruzamiento cromosómico
que es una cosa típica que sucede en la
meiosis 1 y que tiende a suceder de una
manera muy clara donde las secciones
homólogas de estos países homólogos se
entrecruzan estas secciones de los
cromosomas codifican para los mismos
genes son solamente distintas variantes
de esos mismos
los cromosomas pueden tener distintos
alelos recuerdas y una vez más esto
agrega más variación a la reproducción
sexual y esto que sucede es algo
increíble pero ahora vamos a continuar
con la meiosis y en particular con la
meiosis 1 y estoy seguro que puedes
adivinar cuál es la siguiente fase que
diré la siguiente fase que voy a decir
es la meta fase 1 lo voy a poner aquí la
me
está
fase 1
y esta va a tener bastantes similitudes
con la meta fase de la mitosis así que
en la meta fase 1 déjame dibujar a mis
células
voy a tener por aquí a mi celular por
aquí voy a dibujar a mi célula más o
menos así aquí tengo a mi celular y
bueno ahora el núcleo ha desaparecido
después tengo a mis centrosomas los voy
a poner por aquí estos van a tener un
papel más significativo en esta ocasión
y bueno ahora la membrana del núcleo ha
desaparecido y justo como en la meta
fase de la mitosis los cromosomas se van
a se van a alinear sobre este eje
vertical déjame dibujarlo entonces
tenemos primero este cromosoma que tengo
aquí lo voy a poner justo por acá
recuerda que está más o menos así
el otro se ve así le voy a poner algo
así algo así pero en mi final voy a
poner un poco de rosa porque recuerda
que este tuvo un entrecruzamiento con el
otro cromosoma que tengo aquí recuerdas
y después tenemos al otro cromosoma que
tengo aquí se ve más o menos así déjame
ponerlo algo más o menos así y bueno
este va a tener una parte del cromosoma
naranja porque tuvo entrecruzamiento con
él y bueno no olvidemos también poner
los centros los voy a poner de color
azul para que se vean más claramente y
ahora voy a dibujar estos de acá abajo y
voy a suponer que voy a poner aquí aquí
el de color naranja y voy a suponer que
entre ellos no hubo entrecruzamiento así
que no voy a poner una recombinación
homóloga aquí solamente los voy a poner
justo así y por aquí voy a poner el otro
y bueno voy a poner también mi centro
menos uno por aquí y el otro por acá
ahora los centrosomas
en esta ocasión van a tener estos
microtúbulos que voy a dibujar aquí
estos microtúbulos que voy a dibujar
aquí más o menos así este también otro
por acá otro por acá algo más o menos
así
y estos microtúbulos empujan a los
centrosomas uno contra el otro y así los
alejan pero los microtúbulos también se
unen a los neto poros de los cromosomas
justo de esta manera y es muy probable
que oigas a las personas hablar acerca
de que estos microtúbulos lo único que
hacen es alejar conectar y mover cosas
pero a mí me parece esto bastante
increíble es decir como un montón de
proteínas por medio de procesos químicos
y termodinámicos son capaces de hacer
cosas tan interesantes como pueden
hacerle para mover los cromosomas a
distintas partes de la célula para que
eventualmente se puedan formar los
gametos que participan en la
reproducción sexual esto es una cosa
increíble que se desarrolló a lo largo
de miles de millones
de años de evolución y es alucinante el
solo pensar en esta complejidad y saber
que de hecho no todo está completamente
entendido no todo acerca de cómo
trabajan se entiende del todo a lo que
me refiero es que es un proceso
realmente fascinante cómo es que estas
proteínas motoras ayudan a mover a los
cromosomas o cómo es que esos
microtúbulos pueden alargarse o
encogerse de maneras interesantes bueno
de cualquier manera esto es lo que
sucede es la meta fase 1 ahora
seguramente puedes adivinar cuál es el
siguiente proceso que vamos a ver este
va para acá estaba para acá y ahora
vamos a ir para abajo y vamos a ver la
anna fase 1
y justo como él anav hacer de la mitosis
en esta fase los cromosomas comienzan a
separarse pero hay una diferencia
significativa de hecho hay una
diferencia muy grande en la mitosis las
cromatina sermana se separan para poder
convertirse en dos cromosomas hijos pero
esto no sucede en la fase 1 de la
meiosis en la fase 1 las cromatina
semanas van a permanecer juntas el par
homólogo es el que se separan así que
déjame dibujar lo voy a poner aquí en mi
celular déjame dibujarla por acá ok
esta va a ser mi celular esta vez y
bueno voy a dibujar por aquí los
cromosomas tengo primero este de aquí
este de aquí déjame ponerlo más o menos
y un poco más largo para que se vea que
es el cromosoma largo más o menos así
pero le falta este pequeño pedazo de
color rosa muy bien y ahora voy a poner
a este otro cromosoma aquí lo voy a
poner justo por aquí
esto más o menos por aquí y voy a poner
mi parte de este color anaranjado muy
bien y bueno también voy a poner estos
de acá abajo por aquí tengo a este
anaranjado más o menos así es el pequeño
y bueno también voy a poner con este
otro color aquí al pequeño y rosado y
ahora date cuenta que estos están
salados hacia los lados contrarios van
en direcciones opuestas si yo pongo por
acá los centrosomas y voy a poner por
aquí uno de ellos y por acá otro de
ellos me voy a dar cuenta que ellos dos
escalan en direcciones contrarias aquí
suceden mecanismos bastante interesantes
estos microtúbulos de aquí se alargan
empujando los centrosomas en direcciones
opuestas mientras que estos por acá se
acortan jalando los cromosomas hacia los
extremos de la célula separando los
pares homólogos están jalando a estos
cromosomas para que lleguen a los
extremos de la célula y esta separación
puede ser al azar o sea que este rosa
puede quedar del lado derecho
y este puede quedar del lado izquierdo o
viceversa y una vez más esto agrega más
variación entre los gametos entonces
esto lleva a que los gametos que son
producidos tengan distinta información
genética y justo esto es lo que pasa en
la fase 1
los padres homólogos son separados y
bueno seguramente te puedes imaginar qué
es lo que va a suceder en la tele o fase
1 así que déjame poner aquí aquí vamos a
ver qué es lo que más sucede en la tele
fase
y esta fase es muy similar a lo que
sucede en la mitosis va a comenzar las
citocinas ys y bueno de hecho puede
comenzar un poco antes en la mitosis
empieza casi igual que la fase pero
recuerda que en esta fase los cromosomas
ya van a estar completamente separados y
alejados entre ellos así que la voy a
poner más o menos así algo más o menos
así los cromosomas ya están
completamente separados así que los voy
a poner aquí están en extremos opuestos
y de hecho comienzan a desarrollarse así
que voy a poner a uno por aquí a este lo
voy a poner por aquí y bueno voy a poner
por acá esta otra parte la voy a poner
más o menos así y no olvidemos esta
parte de color rosa así que voy a usar
este color y bueno también tengo este de
acá abajo lo voy a poner más o menos así
ya se está desarrollando algo más o
menos así y bueno también lo tengo por
acá tengo a este más o menos así lo voy
a poner largo
más o menos así y de este otro lado pero
también tenemos esta otra parte de la
recombinación lo voy a poner algo más o
menos así para que lo recordemos y bueno
aquí tengo me falta este de aquí verdad
este de aquí lo voy a poner justo así y
bueno algo más o menos así también la
membrana nuclear empieza de nuevo a
formarse algo muy parecido a esto que
estoy dibujando algo muy parecido a esto
que estoy dibujando comienza a formarse
de nuevo
y si te das cuenta es de cierta manera
el proceso inverso a la profa se uno se
va a volver a formar esta membrana
nuclear recuerda aquí la membrana
nuclear desaparece y los cromosomas se
condensan y aquí la membrana nuclear
aparece y los cromosomas se desenrollan
y ahora voy a dibujar los centrosomas
los voy a poner más o menos por acá ya
están muy pero muy pegados a los
extremos lo voy a poner así están afuera
de la membrana nuclear
también estos microtúbulos estaban
desapareciendo así que los voy a poner
así están desapareciendo y ya casi está
acabado este dibujo y bueno recuerda que
está sucediendo las citocinas así que lo
voy a poner así y esto se está separando
en dos células y bueno con esto acabamos
la tele fase 1 que viene después de la
fase 1 y pasamos de aquí a acá muy bien
todo lo que vimos en este vídeo lo
podemos ver en este resumen dijimos mira
empezamos con una célula germinal
diploide y después hemos pasado todo
esto hasta llegar aquí a tener dos
células a floyd es estas no son el
producto final porque todas estas fases
de las que hemos pasado por ahorita
todas estas fases forman lo que se
conoce como meiosis 1 todo esto es lo
que se conoce como meiosis 1 déjame
ponerlo así pero en el siguiente vídeo
vamos a hablar de la meiosis 2 en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a hablar de la
meiosis 2 y por eso voy a escribir aquí
que todo esto que vimos es parte de la
me
y oh sí
todo esto formó parte de la meiosis 1 y
puedes ver que cada una de estas dos
células tiene un número amplio de
cromosomas así que eso también es
importante lo voy a escribir con este
color tenemos aquí un número
pero aplaude
d
igual a 2 date cuenta que es igual a 2
porque tenemos dos cromosomas aquí lo
que vamos a ver en la meiosis 2 es muy
similar a la mitosis cada uno de estos
dos cromosomas tiene dos cromatina
semanas y éstas van a ser separadas así
darán lugar a dos cromosomas hijos
entonces aquí tu número a floyd es dos
tenemos dos cromosomas aquí dos
cromosomas acá y en el siguiente vídeo
exploraremos qué sucede con la meiosis